I don't know if any of you have seen
this it's been going around say YouTube
video of an old couple trying to get
their webcam to work yes a lot of people
have seen this and the old people trying
to get their webcam to work and they
don't know it but they're being recorded
the whole time and then this thing got
out on the internet so far it has had
seven million views seven million views
check it out look at the monkey did a
capture I put on capture that's a pretty
good monkey
I'm going to say here take a photo
snapshot okay wait a minute what's what
it just froze show more Allen it's just
this is the part that gets really good
we're trying it'll be up in a minute
okay you know I can probably get it on
my laptop oh really my laptop over here
cool see if you can get it up because
it's funny it gets even better it's much
better it gets really good yeah my Wi-Fi
password here okay do you have it yet
well give me a minute I mean hold your
horses I'm trying to get it up that's
what you told your wife
do that
I'm doing this for all of us
[Music]
[Music]
smartest person I like this look that
look
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I'm Davi from Harry Potter well we
have an amazing show ladies and
gentlemen from the CBS series sunny Bay
is here where is the member from the
box-office hit the help in the new movie
fifty-fifty Bryce Dallas Howard on the
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]